foreign
administration had everything that they
needed here in place and as you can see
this is enough wall section to complete
all of the areas that Governor Ducey
used the containers to cover up
so had the administration done its job
then Governor Ducey would not have had
to have acted with the legislature using
State resources instead of the federally
funded wall that we had already paid for
more or less you have about two million
dollars worth of concrete and steel
barriers that have been in place and
have been inactive since the day after
the inauguration
unfortunately Governor Ducey had to take
action when the federal government
refused to continue construction on the
wall and Governor DC brought in the
containers
even though right around the corner as I
showed you we have all of the materials
bought and paid for by the taxpayers of
the United States where this wall should
have been completed so these are working
as you notice we don't have any crossing
right here
very many people are excited about
trying to scale the containers
especially with the barbed wire over the
top of it but this used to be the main
entry route
this Gap is closed up one of the reasons
that I was frustrated that this wall was
not completed is because just behind us
we have a pathway where people were
taking a tourist bus being dropped off
and then walking across so we had
thousands of people coming through this
area on a daily basis but because of the
governor's action we don't have that
anymore
thanks to the containers we almost have
zero traffic in this area
which is located right next to the city
of Yuma so they would be in a
residential neighborhood within less
than a mile of crossing over in this
area
I don't want to speak for governor Ducey
but he is committed to keeping those
containers in place until the federal
government steps up and does its job